bienvenue dans ce piège vous pensiez
voir la vidéo du million mais vous êtes
ici enfermé à l'intérieur d'une vidéo le
temps vous est compté et vous avez
seulement ce timing pour vous en sortir
relever le défi et bienvenue dans ce
premier et skype vidéo à la fin de
chaque séquence vous devrez prendre un
chemin un choix simple mais ô combien
primordial
il sera affiché à l'écran et en
descriptions ne quittez jamais une vidéo
avant la fin laisse hélas filet en
entier ne vous souciez pas du temps qui
passe tout est calculé automatiquement
si vous respectez ces quelques règles
réglons les fonctions pause avancer
reculer et les autres vitesse de lecture
sont proscrites
règle 2 vous ne reviendrez jamais sur
les vidéos précédentes
règle 3 ne mangez pas trop gras trop
sucré trop salé
nous calculons le temps pour vous bonne
chance mashal a un oeil pour oeil dent
pour dent
wesh wesh les menthe à l'eau
[Musique]
[Rires]